AVEENO®
HEALTHY. IT’S OUR NATURE.
CARLEY: MORE THAN TWO DOZEN
MANHATTAN PARENT FILING LAWSUITS
FENCE THE CITY DEMANDING THE
FULL REOPENING OF SCHOOLS.
THE SUIT ARGUES THAT THE
INABILITY TO OFFER FULL, FIVE
DAY A WEEK IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
WITH TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM
IS A VIOLATION OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION THREE PARENTS WHICH
HAVE HELPED ORGANIZE THE EFFORT
WHICH HAS RAISED $0,000 JOIN ME
NOW.
IN ANATALIA.
ALISON WANGER AND STEPHANIE
COCOA KNOWS.
THEY ALL JOIN ME.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL.
YOU THREE HELPED ORGANIZE THIS
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE NEW YORK
CITY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
MAYOR BILL DE BLASIO.
NATALIA, I WILL START WITH YOU,
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS LAWSUIT IS
NECESSARY AND WHAT ARE YOU
HOPING TO ACHIEVE?
>> WELL, WE HAVE WATCHED OUR
KIDS AND OTHER KIDS IN OUR CITY
BE LOCKED OUT OF CLASSROOMS
SINCE MARCH OF 2020.
AND WE KEPT HOPING FOR A PLAN.
WE THOUGHT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD OUR KIDS’
BEST INTEREST.  WE THOUGHT ANY
DAY NOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO GET
EVERY KID BACK INTO SCHOOL LIKE
OTHER CITIES HAVE.
AND THEY HAVE ACROSS EUROPE.
AND THAT HASN’T HAPPENED.
SO, WE HAVE ADVOCATED.
WE HAVE RALLIED.
WE HAVE MARCHED, WE HAVE BEGGED,
WE HAVE TWEETED.
WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING WE COULD
AND NOW IT’S TIME TO COMPEL THE
CITY TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
SO MANY KIDS ARE STILL SHUT OUT
OF CLASSROOMS AND IT’S
UNACCEPTABLE.
WE CANNOT WAIT ANOTHER DAY.
CARLEY: ALISON, SAME QUESTION TO
YOU, WHY DO YOU THINK LEGAL
ACTION IS NECESSARY AND ALSO,
HOW DID AT-HOME LEARNING AFFECT
YOUR CHILDREN?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK IT’S
NECESSARY BECAUSE WE KEEP
HEARING FROM DR. FAUCI, FROM OUR
GOVERNOR, FROM OUR MAYOR, THEY
ALL KEEP SAYING HOW CLEAR THE
DATA IS THAT SCHOOL IS SAFE AND
THAT KIDS SHOULD BE IN SCHOOL.
SO IT’S CONFUSING ON WHY OUR
KIDS AREN’T BACK AT SCHOOL FULL
TIME WHEN SO MANY DESPERATELY
WANT TO BE BACK AND TRULY
SUFFERING.
MY KIDS, FORTUNATELY JUST WENT
BACK FULL TIME REMOTE WAS
DIFFICULT ON THEM.
HARD TO FOCUS ON COMPUTER
SCREENS AND WORK SHE’D.
OUR TEACHERS DID AMAZING JOB AS
PEST AS THEY COULD IN ISOLATED
ENVIRONMENT.
CARLEY: I KNOW YOU HAVE TWO
7-YEAR-OLD TWINS.
GOOD FOR YOU.
STEPHANIE, YOU HAVE A 5-YEAR-OLD
AND 7-YEAR-OLD.
YOUR KIDS ALSO WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL ALREADY.
HAVE YOU SEEN A CHANGE IN THEM
FROM WHAT THEY WERE LIKE WHEN
THEY WERE LEARNING AT HOME
VERSUS NOW THAT THEY ARE BACK IN
SCHOOL?
IT’S NIGHT AND DAY HONESTLY,
WHEN YOU HAVE A 5-YEAR-OLD
TRYING TO LEARN SOCIAL SKILLS
AND LIFE SKILLS IN FRONT OF A
SCREEN, IT’S JUST NOT
AGE-APPROPRIATE.
AND THEY ARE FLOURISHING RIGHT
NOW WITH THEIR TEACHERS.
CARLEY: YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
NATAYLIA YOU HAVE A 7 AND
10-YEAR-OLD.
MAYOR de BLASIO, HE ACTUALLY
SPOKE OUT YESTERDAY ABOUT SCHOOL
REOPENINGS.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN TO
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
WATCH.
>> WE MADE OUR SCHOOLS THE
SAFEST PLACES IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE COMEBACK OF THE NEW YORK
CITY SCHOOLS, BIGGEST SCHOOL
SYSTEM IN THE NATION.
THE FACT THAT WE REOPENED OUR
SCHOOLS WHEN SO MANY OTHER
CITIES DIDN’T EVEN DARE TO TRY.
I WANT EVERYBODY BACK IN SCHOOL
IN SEPTEMBER, EVERYBODY.
CARLEY: A FEW TAKE AWAYS FROM
THAT ON MY END IS THAT HE THINKS
THAT HE HANDLED SCHOOLS, HIS
ADMINISTRATION HANDLED SCHOOLS
IN NEW YORK CITY IN A REALLY
GREAT WAY.
ANSWERED ALSO DOES SAY THAT HE
WANTS SCHOOLS TO BE BACK FULL
TIME IN THE FALL.
DOES THAT G.E. YOU ANY COMFORT.
>> SURE.
GIVES ME A LOT OF COMFORT BUT IT
DOESN’T ACTUALLY GIVE ME
ANYTHING BINDING AND DOESN’T
SHOW THAT THERE IS A PLAN THAT
PARENTS CAN TRULY RELY ON.
IS HE ALSO THE ONE WHO SAID THAT
NEW YORK CITY HAS HAD A GOLD
STANDARD OF REOPENING.
I WILL DISAGREE.
I WOULD SAY PLACES LIKE BRAL NEW
JERSEY WHERE THEY DIDN’T SHUT
DOWN ENTIRE SCHOOLS FOR TWO
UNRELATED CASES AND KEPT KIDS IN
SCHOOL PRETTY MUCH FULL TIME
FROM EARLY THIS YEAR THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE MY SENSE OF WHAT A
GOLD STANDARD IS.
SO I BELIEVE THE MAYOR WANTS TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
I THINK HIS HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE.
I THINK HE IS HAMSTRUNG BY
PEOPLE LIKE MICHAEL MULGREW AND
RANDI WEINGARTEN WHO HAVE
EXTORTED THIS CITY AND THIS
COUNTRY AND HAS KEPT BLUE
SWATHES OF THIS COUNTRY SHUT
DOWN AT THE KIDS’ EXPENSE.
AND THEY ARE SPINNING THE STORY
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
TRYING TO REOPEN BUT, IN FACT,
WE HAVE NO CONFIDENCE THAT THEY
HAVE THE KIDS’ BEST INTEREST AT
HEART.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
DO THIS IS TO ACTUALLY DO THIS
AND WIN IT.
CARLEY: ALISON, HAVE YOU GOTTEN
ANY PLAN IN PLACE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF NEXT YEAR AND YOUR
KIDS DO GO BACK TO IN PEPPER AND
THEN A CHILD TESTS POSITIVE FOR
COVID?
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CLASSROOM?
HAS ANYBODY TOLD YOU ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT?
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO PLAN,
NOTHING.
THERE IS NO PLANS ON, YOU KNOW,
I KNOW MAYOR de BLASIO SAID
THAT, THAT HE WANTS THAT.
BUT THERE IS NO PLANS.
THERE IS NOTHING.
HE HAS ANNOUNCED THAT NEW YORK
CITY IS OPENING UP.
WE HAVE THEATERS AND BROADWAY
AND REALLY EXCITING, BUT HE HAS
NOT MENTIONED THE PLAN FOR HOW
NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS ARE GOING
TO OPEN AND THE PARENTS ARE VERY
NERVOUS AND WE’RE SCRAMBLING.
CARLEY: STEPHANIE, HAVE YOU
HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT HOW THE
FALL IS GOING TO BE HANDLED?
>> I DON’T.
I MEAN, I DO KNOW THAT WE ARE
STILL TESTING OUR CHILDREN
WEEKLY.
SO WE ARE TESTING OUR CHILDREN
ASYMPTOMATICALLY AND ANY TIME
THAT THERE IS A CODE-POSITIVE
CASE, REGARDLESS IF IT IS A
FALSE NEGATIVE OR A FALSE
POSITIVE, RATHER OUR CLASSROOMS
ARE CLOSED AND EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE BACK.
SOME ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS ARE BACK
FIVE DAYS WE STILL ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE CLASSROOM CLOSURES
UNNECESSARILY.
CARLEY: YOU THREE ARE TAKING
ACTION.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO MAYOR
de BLASIO’S OFFICE AND THE NEW
YORK CITY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
BUT HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.